hi everyone I'm Tania Rivero thank you
for joining us Tom Hanks plays Mister
Rogers in the highly anticipated new
movie a beautiful day in the
neighborhood the Academy Award winning
actor says he initially turned down the
part but director Mary L Heller changed
his mind
CBS this morning co-host Gayle King sat
down with Hanks for an extended
discussion about the movie but it's you
I like you every part are very valuable
here doesn't matter doesn't that's what
I think Fred was able to make people
feel they not necessarily better not
necessarily stronger but Fred made
people feel worthwhile for over three
decades it's a beautiful day Fred Rogers
was America's favorite neighbor would
you and now Tom Hanks is stepping into
the shoes hello neighbor of the beloved
children's television host in a new film
inspired by the man touched the hearts
of millions I didn't know what to expect
Tom when I walked in the theater I knew
it wasn't a biopic but I think most
people walking in will think that it's a
biopic like Fred Rogers from cradle to
grave yes then a young man was born he
had a dream yes and then people say well
okay Fred Rogers played by Tom Hanks of
course it is but I think people should
understand this is truly truly acting he
had been this iconographic Johnny Carson
did goofs on Fred Rogers Eddie Murphy
did goofs on Fred Rogers his cadence and
the sound of him became this kind of
like signature of cluelessness or he was
a commodity in this in this way and as
soon as as soon as you become that
commodity that is known for this very
specific sound and look the sweaters and
the blue sneakers and whatnot well then
it's like how do you act as a can of
coca-cola or a Frigidaire refrigerator
it's just as a thing and Fred Roth Fred
was so specific about what he did on
camera he's stringing together words and
with a rhythm and in order to examine a
theme various
civically and that's what fred did on
every one of these programs and because
he spoke slowly and thoughtfully yeah it
became this kind of like signature of
Thane as a four little word like tape or
zoom did you know much about him we
would have been nine yeah I didn't pay
any attention it was this odd show that
looked very cheesy the puppets their
mouths didn't move and it was so obvious
that he was doing all the different
kinds of voices and so I remember seeing
it you know when you're 13 14 years old
and I was already saying come on cut
move to something else make it a little
snappier it's not for 9 year olds it's
for an impressionable mind that does not
know how the world works at all I'm
proud of you and I've certainly learned
a lot by knowing every person I talked
to who said oh when you spoke to Fred
you felt you felt like you were the only
person in the world that mattered to him
that's a gift home it's a gift but it's
also a practice we are trying to give
the world positive ways of dealing with
and feelings Hank's brought mr. Rogers
to life with a little help from the
woman who knew him best jo-ann Rogers
his wife of 50 years
we're told Joanne rogers lent you some
of his ties all of his ties I don't know
if that gives you an extra special
feeling or if it meant something to you
anytime you have some sort of like kind
of like little talisman like that in
there it ends up being special that's a
big deal but I read that you turned it
down three times this part well I
wouldn't say three times five times well
the way it works is well you turned it
down before in the business of show Gail
I'm so glad you asked me this question
yeah the business of show there are
these things that come out say hey here
is a hot property here is a screenplay
that these guys have written off and
it's going to become something and I
read it when there was nobody attached
it was just such a hundred twenty pages
of a screenplay and there was no
filmmaker attached there was nothing
that's like you can control this if you
want to and I when I read it I said okay
I get the mr. Rogers thing I guess
that's interesting but at the end of the
day this is about a guy going through
you know a crisis that is can be very
common amongst men
father issues wife issues baby issues
and I didn't know what it was I didn't I
didn't turn down something that was
already the specific thing I turned down
this kind of quasi blank canvas and it
existed like that for a real long time
but a chance meeting brought Hanks back
to the story of Mister Rogers here we
are this is our first day on our
neighborhood set that's Tom Hanks right
over there I love how you and the
director meet and how this how this
collaboration came about I met Mari at
the week that an article in The New York
Times came out about women filmmakers
and I had read it and literally 24 hours
before I went to his birthday party for
my grandkids and I said no what do you
is I'm a director so I just read this
interesting article the New York Times
about female directors have you seen it
and she to me she said I'm in it please
let me remove my shoe from my mouth so
chatted with her there and I heard about
her film Diary of a teenage girl and I
also immediately took a look at it and
said this lady's going places he said I
want to work with her when she attached
herself to this a beautiful day in the
neighborhood
and after a one read and a quick phone
call with her I said this is only just a
matter of when we can do it she said she
did not want you to be an imitation of
Fred Rogers well the conversation okay
so let's start with the most obvious
aspect the look I'm all we gonna do
teeth I don't have the same nose what
are we going to said you'll have a wig
and we'll do something with your
eyebrows so the rest is about you
embodying the pulse the heartbeat the
sensibility the motivations of why Fred
Rogers commanded a room in the way that
the way that he did and I don't say you
could probably say you could command the
room but it's funny at WQED the studio
in Pittsburgh where we recreated the set
and everybody just coming by and said oh
I haven't seen this in Co 1992 it it was
right down to the door knocker the
people at QED who had known Fred who had
worked with Fred we actually had his
lighting
director was the guy sitting right there
so he did the TV series and he also did
the movie they all said that Fred there
was no question about when Fred was in
the building
meaning that he was the boss at the end
of the day he's kind of like Elvis
walking in you know mmm but Fred being
in the building meant that there was
going to be an attention paid to the
process of making this very very
specific children's TV show
it was extremely thought out there were
there were times when Fred had I saw the
scripts you know I saw had written in
his own hand you know on legal tablets
and in the in the archives there would
be moments where he would come across
and wonder if he was doing it right if
he was actually addressing the theme of
that particular show in which he would
stop production and go off and talk to
his advisors his children's
psychologists and seminarians in order
to make sure that he was putting out
something that was what he was
purporting to put out there's so many
things people can do in this world
many wonderful things that help people
and not hurt people here was an ordained
minister who never once mentioned God in
any of his you never said anything
remember God loves you or they never
said anything like that and his quote
that he loved was was from the city of
Zuppa raised the little prince was that
which is most essential is invisible to
the eye
that means that there is a force that a
human being can use on another human
being that is meant to make that person
feel safe what was the hardest thing for
you Tom about this part because I am
fast going down slowing down not
interrupting people in the middle of the
Maskin question not jumping to the
Kaluza the I know exactly what I'm going
to say well you're still trying to
formulate a question there but it's more
than just slowing down there's your
inflection it's your expression yeah
it's more than that it's more than
slowing down you have to start at a
place where the first challenge that you
you have to lay down for yourself as an
actor is what's the big beat here
that is there gonna be demanded of me
and number one it was that cadence can
you give us an example Tom of how you
practice to get it right because you
really did nail it well and it had to
take practice to do that well and acting
an awful lot of it is if I was to take
you to the movie and and I would I would
I would say I'm now going to tell you
what was my first day of shooting on
this film you'd say oh yeah yeah cuz you
kind of talk a little faster there it's
a just it's just a little different
because a lot of ways I don't think
you're really in tune with the DNA of a
movie until you're shooting on the third
day I think it takes about three days in
order to was it hard for you to do it
was it was terrifying it was yeah you
know it's interesting to hear that it's
terrifying because people think that of
all the roles that you've done this
would be a lot for you to do and
certainly the easiest for you to do
there's no such thing as an easy role to
do because at the moment the moment I
said yes I began to have the night
sweats that go along with trying to play
look I have played a lot of real people
fred was a very very public persona and
everybody has an idea of what fred is
what Fred was like the mysteries behind
Fred we even get to address it in the
movie somebody says do you have a lot of
tattoos
you know under the because there was
that folklore that that he was a Navy
SEAL and said his body was covered with
tattoos but the the the terror that goes
along with it is that you want to land
in a place that people recognize as his
true human behavior whether it playing
somebody who's real or somebody who's
not and if it's not authentic you're
actively lying in in an art form that is
supposed to be holding the mirror up to
nature that attention to authenticity is
that the core of every Tom Hanks role
must be hard being the king the Academy
Award winner has played a range of
characters with his everyman charm but
there are some roles he says he just
won't do you don't seem to gravitate
toward bad guy roles is that deliberate
on your part I don't I have made them
guys who did bad thing yeah it's the
it's the motivation
this bad guy roll that I don't I don't
buy even as when I was young I didn't
not like movies that were just a
standard antagonist protagonist bent
James Bond movies are really cool I
absolutely love them but how often I
don't understand a guy who just says
before I kill you Mr Bond perhaps you'd
like a tour of our installation I don't
get it I the shakespeare has great I
would love to play Yago I would love to
play Richard that there's all sorts of
really bad people out there but I
understand what their motivations are
the person who is just bad be it
Skeletor or Darth Vader or something
like that
at the end of day I said but why what
what turned there do you consider
yourself a hero I don't think of myself
as a hero did playing this role change
you they all do
one way or another Fred Rogers there we
every day on the call sheet
there was an attached quote of Fred's
and sometimes they were long and
sometimes it were very very simple one
was there are three and the three
secrets of happiness are be kind be kind
and be kind and you think well that's
namby-pamby that's goodie two-shoe no
matter what your bent is being kind
means you give everybody a fair shake
being kind is is just being open to a
possibility of making a simple choice it
makes a day a little bit better you just
take a minute and think about all the
people who
loved us in to be it's very riveting
where he says think about the people
that loved you into being yeah tom i sat
there and you could have heard a pin
drop in the theater because I think
we're all asking ourselves that question
and the answer is sometimes very sad but
it's also very exciting I mean it chokes
me up thinking about that moment when we
were doing it I asked Mari said yeah
we're really gonna do this because
silence makes people uncomfortable and
that silence in a movie is deadly I
think one of the reasons why that is so
uncomfortable one certainly because it's
very very personal because everybody
goes to a very specific place
individually there is no this is the bad
thing that happened to me this is not
I'm still bitter about this it's a
question about who made you the best
version of yourself that you've ever
been and it is that lack of blame it is
that lack of cynicism that I think is
almost it's scary in order to come
across because it's not our it's not our
default mode and I think maybe that's
why I'm so excited for people to see it
because this movie seems to be coming
out at a time when we need it most
am i overthinking it here well I think
it might be a comment on the yin and
yang of where we are right now I don't
want to overuse the word cynicism but
there's it seems to be the easiest way
to make a buck and the easiest way to
win an argument is to go right to this
place of you know the standard
us-versus-them dilemma and in Fred
Rogers neighborhood
there's no then it's just us you know
and when he says hey oh I got an
invitation to go to a to a concert want
to come along come on let's go and you
see that little toy city it's like let's
go see the other people that inhabit our
world that actually make our world a
better place
you